das ist heute eine echte ja man muss
sagen weltpremiere wir starten ein neues
format mit unserem kleinen netzwerk von
silence youtube kanälen 1054 den nerd
heute fachsimpeln hierbei klicks um sie
direkt von doktor watson und jakob von
breaking lab über das für und wider von
künstlicher intelligenz ki und eine
frage zieht sich wie ein roter faden
durch das video wird die menschheit
eines tages von ki vernichtet werden
also beide kanäle unbedingt abonnieren
denn der nächste nerd ob könnte da
online gegen los geht's recht gab hat
ein programmierer dem algorithmus gesagt
was er detektieren soll und welche
schlüsse er daraus ziehen soll und
dieses was erfinden soll oder was er
analysieren soll das macht die jetzt
selber ist das schon mal eine ganz gute
eingrenzung oder liege ich komplett
daneben
ja so ganz kann man das natürlich nicht
sagen es gibt eigentlich drei formen von
maschinellen lernens gibt einmal das
super weiß burning das ist ich gebe
bilder vor zum beispiel also ist es um
computer vision geht wenn es darum geht
bilder zu erkennen ich gebe bilder vor
und sage was ich sage das ist ein hund
katze das ist ein zebra dann gibt's das
zweite das ist das ein super weist
burning da sein kann ich vorher nicht
was weiß ich selber meistens vorher gar
nicht was möchte ich denn genau
detektieren sondern ich gebe die die die
proben rein ist
den input rheins kann man halt und
welche bilder sein können und welche
zahlenwerte sein und die ki die sucht
dann nach mustern drin
das ist einfach schaut ja was gehört das
zusammen was passt da zusammen und
erstellt daraus selber gruppen da gibt
man meistens noch vor und wie viele
gruppen haben möchte
genau aber es ist das geht so ein
bisschen mehr in deine richtung und die
dritte version das ist das wie
enforcement learning und da geht es
darum dass man regeln schafft aber nicht
sagt wie etwas zu lösen ist also ganz
typisches beispiel sind das so
computerspiele wehrmann dino spiel
programmiert
wo wir eine ki das haben spielen lassen
ja nur gesagt okay dann mit der taste
springst du und das ist ein spielfeld
und das sind die punkte und die punkte
müssen möglichst hoch gehen und das
trainiert dann selber was muss ich
machen damit ich möglichst viele punkte
kriegen und deswegen ist es halt also
beim super weiß learning kann man sagen
okay man gibt schon sehr viel vor
bei man super weiß berlin muss man also
was man hier immer macht dass man
definiert dieses netz und das hat super
viel einfluss wie ich das definieren was
das netz nachher kann und machen kann
dann frage ich mal es gibt zum beispiel
folgt ich glaub start von google
woran erkennt das war glaube ich eben
hier google brain trainiert woran
erkannte dass züge in syrien an den
schiene und dann war ich total verblüfft
weil das hat die krise selber
herausbekommen woran sie züge erkennen
ja also ich meine es hat natürlich viele
beispiele gegeben wo du züge siehst das
hat er nicht das okay das ist ein zug
denken normal sondern das ist in die
mitte das ist dieses super weißdorn ich
habe gesagt dass das das dass das dass
das in züge und das hat gesehen auch
gast da sind ja maschinen drauf also
mathematisch und hat deswegen gelernt ok
schienen gleich zu aber es hat nicht
selber also woher soll es auch diesen
zug ist na ja klar nein das ist
natürlich total
und da sind wir beim thema es ist
natürlich total ab sagt das ding erkennt
nur da ist so eine dunkle fläche da sind
da sind spiegelungen drauf ist erkennt
bestimmte charaktere aber das sind immer
diese beiden linien drauf und gehen das
ist für mich ein zeichen dessen zug und
jetzt ist die ja die ganz große frage
sind wir nicht auch so simpel gestrickt
und empfinden wir uns nicht nur viel
intelligenter als die ki aber sind es
eigentlich gar nicht gemacht
diese einfache frage gern ein
na ja schon in dem sie intelligenter als
dass wir den zug auf und stimmen
erkennen
wenn du jetzt durch die luft fliegt dann
würde mir trotzdem sagen dass das ein
zug aber wir machen das wahrscheinlich
etwas detaillierter weil wir suchen uns
auch bestimmte markante punkte aus an
dem wir fest machen was ist in zukunft
kein zug dann geht es natürlich
irgendwann einfach eine definitionsfrage
rein wenn man immer tiefer geht was ist
eigentlich ein zug wenn verschiedene
autos andere reißt es das nicht auch ein
zug irgendwo auch wenn er nicht auch
schon der 100 watt und auf die gleichen
spurbreiten setzen und plötzlich kann
das ding auf schienen frage was ist
eigentlich so gut dass es dann aber
sowieso wieder anfragen gar nicht denn
mensch definieren sollte aber am ende
des tages kugel wir auch nach bestimmten
punkten die für uns sagen wenn das und
das und das der fall ist dann ist das
ein zug wenn es besonders lang ist unter
leute reingehen und von damit von punkt
a nach punkt b com ist das für uns
meistens hinzu was da vielleicht noch
ganz interessant ist also das ist würde
ich genauso unterstützen und ein
beispiel was ist einfach zeigt dass das
stimmt ist wenn wir also computer vision
ist halt dieses ich arbeite mit bildern
und was da mal gemacht wird man nutzt
sogenannte stents also confusion vinyl
network ptn denn ich habe das sind im
endeffekt sind ja erst mal erstmal
filter ich mein bild weil man gesehen
hat okay also ein bild besteht aus ganz
vielen pixeln das überfordert unsere
rechenleistung weil halt das ist nimmt
ja immer mehr zu mainz vor dem computer
jetzt genau weil wir haben also dann ist
so die erste sache die man immer macht
als wir nehmen die farben raus dann hat
man schon mal pro pixel hält nur noch
schwarz und weiß was ganz gut ist und
was man dann macht ist man setzt so
filter an und sorgt dafür dass also wenn
ich zum beispiel ein foto von dir mache
dann gucke ich dass ich nur noch so die
markanten merkmale also dein gesicht
deiner augen nase mund und das
interessante ist dass man damit in der
lage ist also bei computer vision
genauer dinge festzulegen genauer dinge
zu erkennen
und da ist halt was uns menschen
unterscheidet wir sind viel komplexer
wir haben dann viel viel besseres gehirn
weil wir in der lage sind viel mehr
eindrücke informationen gleichzeitig zu
verarbeiten
ich habe tatsächlich neulich ein video
gemacht da bist besser aufkam neuer
großer ein nein ein kurzer einwurf da
würde ich sagen meinst du wirklich weil
ich finde leider die info nicht ich habe
mal das ist schon 20 jahre in artikel
gelesen da wurde so gesagt modell die
these war wir nehmen jede sekunde knapp
zwei milliarden oder eine milliarde
infos auf wir können aber nur 2000
verarbeiten
und das ist ja wahnsinnig wenig und es
scheint mir realistisch dieser wert
wobei wahrscheinlich war er einfach nur
vermutet weil wenn man sich überlegt was
wir behalten und wenn du zb es gibt ja
dieses berühmte beispiel von leute video
weiß es wie in welcher weise raum mit
leuten in weiß die sich den ball
gegenseitig zu schmeißen
der berühmte gorilla der dann durchläuft
und keiner sieht den ich habe setzt sich
selber erlebt ich habe fotos schnell
durch geguckt und alles was ich
einordnen konnte habe ich auch sofort
erkannt aber da war zum beispiel ein
foto dabei da war mensch drauf und
rechts daneben war irgendwas ich habe im
nachgang nichts sagen können was das war
und musste dann zurückgehen und das war
halt eine hoch spiegelnde gestalt also
zur targobank
das war in meinem erfahrungsbereich
nicht drin
deswegen konnte ich das in der
geschichte konnte es nicht erkennen ich
hatte mein gehirn hat keine möglichkeit
gehabt das in irgendeiner weise
einzuordnen weil es viel zu komplex war
und nicht geübt war
und da würde ich dann wieder sagen
vielleicht sind wir gar nicht so komplex
wie haben wir haben vielleicht heute
sind wir wir sind aufwändiger wir haben
keine ahnung mehr schaltkreise und
können deswegen mehr verarbeiten aber
das ist dann auch noch ne frage da
kommen wir auch nachher zu den
zuschauerfragen wenn eine frage mich was
ist nämlich wenn keiner von kanten
rechner passen läuft ja also ist es dann
gegen mensch eine sache dazu es gibt ein
dass der westen denkt man dann wie du
hast ja ja ich habe also habe ich habe
dazu neustadt ein video gemacht wo ich
verglichen habe menschliches diverse
künstliche intelligenz wo hat die
unterschiede haben uns auch so die
rechenleistung die operation angeschaut
und was ganz ganz spannend es gibt ein
buch das ist groß dass von peyman das
ist ein nobelpreisträger der schnelles
denken man sich denken heißt das buch
und es geht um durch zwei gehirn system
los einmal das schnelle denken das was
jetzt passiert was tatsächlich zwar
schon diese ganzen informationen
aufnimmt aber filtert einfach weil es
dabei um effizienz kenia und dann hast
aber noch ein zweites system und das
muss erst aktiviert werden aber das ist
das schlägt jeden computer weil das viel
komplexer denken kann also es ist nicht
einfach okay ich habe gelernt das und
das und das wissen zug sondern das ist
dann okay ich hinterfrage das ganze ich
schaue
also ich bin anscheinend irritiert mein
system eins hat ausgeschlagen ich bin
irritiert ich muss mir das genau
anschauen und das kann dann solche
sachen machen okay das ding fliegt so in
der luft aber es ist trotzdem zu weil
das sieht so aus und hat juristische
system in gang setzen weil im zug der
fliegt genau und das ist für mich der
absolute beweis dafür dass das
menschliche gehirn schlauer ist und da
können auch klein computer bekommen
die werden das glaube ich so nicht
ersetzen können ok also dann wäre schon
mal die these system 1 könnte vielleicht
im quantencomputer setzen mit kunst
intelligenz system zwei sagst du auf
keinen fall oder gar nicht ich weiß
jetzt wenn ich das video in zehn jahren
oder in 20 jahren sehe dann gleich so
ein quatsch die dumm von mir damals sag
niemals nie ich sage niemals nie aber
diese diese prognosen jahre leute sagen
oh gott die ki wird uns in den nächsten
zehn jahren ersetzen das ist meiner
meinung nach total übertrieben und man
kann auch als ich habe wirklich viele
studien zu diesem thema gelesen weil ich
nicht mal mit arbeitswelt der zukunft
und digitalisierung ist erstarrt er
beschäftigt habe und man sieht überall
dass die leute sagen
die nehmen uns die jobs weg und das
machen die seit 20 30 jahren oder so was
und wenn du dir das mal durchliest dann
siehst du auch dass die null verständnis
davon haben was eine ki kann wie die
funktioniert und also wirklich hab so
ein schwachsinn gelesen dass wegen
dadurch braucht man sich da eigentlich
keine sorgen machen
jena zu ja ich glaube auch dass sowas
wie excel viel mehr jobs in
anführungszeichen weggenommen hat aber
das hat dazu geführt dass wir heute dazu
in der lage sind viel genauer
prognostizieren zu können wir können ja
heute mit software eben nicht nur das
geschäft berechnen sondern wir können ja
mit software sehen keine ahnung in fünf
wochen habe ich dem dem umsatz und ich
muss jetzt schon produzieren damit ich
den erreiche und so weiter und so fort
dann aber hatte mama du hast das werden
wir nicht erreichen das radeln was war
denn was war denn irgendwas hat sich
noch als genau die andere kritik ist ja
nicht dass wir uns
dass die ki und die jobs weg nimmt
sondern dass sie uns umbringen
weswegen ihr dazu ich würde vielleicht
wollen wir ganz gut zu den jobs kennen
weil ein anderer punkt ist für mich noch
dass technologie hat schon immer dafür
gesorgt dass wir menschen jobs verlieren
hat aber auf dauer in meinen gesehen
dafür gesorgt dass auch die jobs besser
werden
also wir müssen jetzt nicht mehr den
dänen den ak ii mit dem flug in die
durchgehend sondern wir haben zwischen
ist ein landwirt der 5000 menschen
ernähren kann anstatt wie früher wo ein
mensch vielleicht maximal drei oder vier
menschen ernähren konnte das hat dafür
gesorgt dass wir jetzt hier sitzen
können und mit der kamera arbeiten oder
dass die menschen am computer arbeiten
wesentlich angenehmer künstlich
intelligenz geht immer relativ ähnliche
richtung zumindest aktuell noch dass
viele repetitive aufgaben die wir
menschen zwar bisher machen mussten zum
beispiel was bilderkennung daten
eintragungen zwar dass die von ihr
konzipierte games übernommen werden
das ist auch er dieses system eins und
jetzt kommts zu bringen oder wollen wir
noch überarbeitet wird reden also ich
weiß nicht ich hab mich halt ich würde
dieses studium dazu angeschaut und man
konnte nämlich sehen dass es dass es
nicht stimmt das eigentlich immer jobs
dazukommen
es war verlagert sich so ein bisschen
die arbeitswelt aber ein faktor der
super wichtig dabei ist wir werden
effizienter und das heißt wir können
dinge günstiger herstellen und das heißt
wir können mehr konsumiert wir haben
also es gibt diesen punkt also auf dauer
gleicht sich das wieder aus
aber ja also sagen dann immer beispiel
autonom autos die werden jetzt kommen
und dadurch werden erstmal lkw-fahrer
und taxifahrer ihre jobs verlieren
das wird jetzt nicht von heute auf
morgen passieren aber tendenziell werden
relativ viele menschen jetzt auf den
markt kommen die dann sagen ich finde
meinen job ich krieg keinen job mehr ich
kann als last kraftfahrer nicht mehr
arbeiten weil der neue tesla truck macht
das für unseren für unsere firma einfach
günstiger es kommen aber viele neue jobs
dadurch wieder auf dem markt von leuten
die das programmieren müssen von leuten
die das erstmal in stand setzen müssen
dass das ganze funktioniert es gibt
vielleicht sicherheits fahrern die dann
eine zentrale sitzen und drei
gleichzeitig beobachten
auf dauer wird sich das wieder
ausgleichen und wir werden als
gesellschaft viel effizienter das bringt
uns alle woran wir werden durch alle
eine klinge einen höheren stand an eine
lebensqualität
aber für diese menschen den job
verlieren ist das erst mal ziemlich
scheiße und es große briggs wollen wenn
die 50 jahre alt sind die werden jetzt
nicht mehr studieren
die haben dann zwei 14 15 uhr hat ein
riesiges problem bisschen runterkommen
das ist mir auch noch mal dabei ein mann
da wir haben das ist ein sehr tragisches
phänomen das phänomen der armut aber
dieses phänomen der armut hatten wir vor
100 150 200 jahren noch direkt bei uns
hier vor der tür das darf man nicht
vergessen
ein bauer der seinen eigenen flug
gezogen hat der hat vielleicht ganz
einigermaßen gut leben können aber wenn
dein knie schaden hat war der geliefert
und war arm und das war es gab es jetzt
überall in europa die armut direkt vor
unserer tür
das heißt wir haben ja auch durch diese
technische entwicklung immer mehr armut
beseitigt
die frage die ich mir jetzt stelle ist
kann ki vielleicht uns sogar als
gesellschaft bevor wir zum umbringen
kommen weiter bringen also dass sie zum
beispiel es gibt eben wir wissen dass
wenn fanden rechner funktionieren werden
sie multidimensionale probleme lösen
können wie zum beispiel verkehrslenkung
was heute noch ich sag mal sehr holprig
funktioniert und wie wird in der lage
sein alle verkehrsströme so
synchronisieren zu können dass sie alle
zusammen optimal laufen das kann ein
rechner heute nicht und kann sie zum
beispiel das mit dem klimawandel kann
das gelöst werden kann dass ein indem
sie zum beispiel ohne dass wir das ist
ja das haupt die haupt diskussion müssen
wir alle verzichten ohne dass wir viel
verzichten müssen eben eine optimale
lösung mit wenig verzicht viel komfort
und trotzdem das und und eben der
abwägung wie viel co2 muss ich wieder
aus der atmosphäre nehmen wie viel darf
ich noch rein blasen welche technologien
müssen wirklich abgeschafft werden wo
sie die folgen für die arbeitsplätze am
geringsten und so weiter ist das auch
eine zukunftsperspektive
das sage ich ihm das sage ich immer
allen leuten die sagen oh d k i das wird
uns alle umbringen und so weiter so von
oben kommen sagt jemand das ist ein
riesen wir können ja viele dinge gar
nicht dazu sind wir nicht in der lage
ja also ich meine ganz konkret ich habe
glaube ich von einem jahr mit
entwicklern von siemens gesprochen die
ki nutzen um prognosen also in china die
jammern
als ganz großes problem mit smog alarm
oder sowas und die können das mit der ki
vorhersagen und dann werden so maßnahmen
gemacht wie zum beispiel die ampeln
werden plötzlich auf rot geschaltet es
kostet mehr mit dem taxi zu fahren und
fahrrad fahren wird er belohnt oder
sowas
solche sachen kann extrem gut und was
hier zum beispiel die versorgung der
zukunft angeht also eine sache die super
interessant finde
für die ich schon sehr sehr lange
premiere sind an bord also hamburg es
ist also eher sondern auch nicht mehr
warm bots oder klar
ok also leistet das roboter die farmen
betreiben autonom also alles ist
landwirtschaft landwirtschaft genau und
erstmal gibt es da eine richtig coole
des open source projekt was fun bord
heißt und da kann man sich sehr sehr
günstig und das fest programmieren schön
wärs ich hatte damals überlegt ich würde
gerne einen start up in die richtung
aufmachen dann habe ich diesen schritt
gemacht den man ja immer irgendwann
macht man googelt kreisstadt frustriert
weiß das schon gibt und habe ich das
gesehen und mir genauer angeschaut und
fand aber total gaycken und seitdem bin
ich einfach total davon überzeugt dass
das die der sozialstaat der zukunft
reichlich ist also die idee ist du hast
roboter die sich um alles kümmern
der vorteil ist du hast keine
monokulturen mehr das heißt du brauchst
viel viel weniger pestizide
weil wenn du nicht nur keine meisten auf
kleinfeld pflanzt dann hast du nicht das
problem dass da mal eben parasiten
drüber gehen und deinen ganzen keinen
ganzen erträge zerstören sondern du hast
die möglichkeit pflanzen zu kombinieren
die zum beispiel auch gewisse insekten
und sowas abhalten
dh der farm bord ist in der lage ein
feld zu bewirtschaften wo ich sage mal
alle zehn halme einen mais halben steht
dann kommt gäste dann kommen tomaten
dann kommen
zuckerrüben und so weiter machen genau
das und er kann viel näher aneinander
bauen weil er hat halt viel feinere
tools was zum beispiel super ist weil
wir plötzlich hier in der stadt auf
kleinem raum im idealfall noch vertikal
pflanzen züchten können wir sparen und
die transportwege
wir können wirklich gezielt auf die
leute die in der umgebung sind
produzieren das eigentlich
planwirtschaft metal hätte die ddr mfs
gehabt
wer die planwirtschaft wahrscheinlich
deutlich deutlich besser verlaufen
und tatsächlich ist das so das was ich
mir vorstelle weil muss auch überlegen
du hast einmal die investiert
kosten dann hast du so eine farm da
aufgebaut und so ein staat kann ja über
hunderte jahre rechnen wenn du für die
nächsten 100 jahre deine ganze
bevölkerung mit gutem essen versonnen
das ist das total viel wert okay du hast
ein wichtiges thema angesprochen was mir
schon bevor wir zum umbringen wir
bekommen die ganze zeit im kopf rum geht
ist vielleicht das chinesische
diktatorische system was besseres weil
doch nie mehr die ursache ist würde ich
das jetzt aber es läuft darauf hinaus
weil die sind in der lage eine große
bevölkerung zu ernähren und da müssen
wir uns darüber einig seien dass es
erstmal das wichtigste
es gibt halt keine meinungsfreiheit es
gibt keine demokratie das gibt es alles
nicht aber sie setzen einfach per ordre
de mufti hier würde so was
wahrscheinlich 20 jahre dauern bevor wir
so eine ki einsetzen dürften um in
berlin den verkehr zu regeln die man
anders einfach und sie sind vielleicht
dazu denn dadurch in der lage die
probleme der welt zu lösen
im moment sieht es so aus es ist ein
kommunistisches system und das
funktioniert ist nicht pleite gegangen
wie alle anderen sollten trainiert was
ich halte china für extrem
fortschrittlich und aber wie kann es nur
das jetzt sagen also lasst doch
offensichtlich also erstmal ist es also
ich habe letztens noch mit dem mann
gesprochen der aus china kommt und wer
meint das ist nicht so krass wir das
jetzt hier berichtet bekommen
die westlichen medien übertreiben an
einigen stellen dieses system mit den
credits ist definitiv noch nicht alle
umfassen und überall sondern es gibt ein
paar communitys städte die das schon mal
ausprobieren testweise gut man könnte
natürlich sagen die entgegen die
arbeiten und denken an dich schon weiter
und ab 2020 2021
was wird das dann doch irgendwann kommen
muss man beobachten aber es ist
definitiv also es definitiv nicht das
bessere system in den augen
also es die scheinen also es gab ja
letzten umfrage die bürger in china
scheinen das sogar zu befürworten
das system das das credit system finden
das sogar gut dass sie da so lautet das
thema das ist das system oder punkte für
gute taten und negativpunkte schlechte
taten wenn du halt einem die tür vor der
nase zu punkten
abgezogen wenn der mir die tür aufhält
und das auf alle gesellschaftlichen
bereiche thema umweltverschmutzung
energieverbrauch auf alles aber auch im
porno konsum aber auch wohlverhalten
gegenüber der partei die unterstützung
des kommunistischen systems und soweit
einfach alles ist du wirst bepunktet als
mensch und wenn du ich sag mal wie hier
politisch sich gegen systemen
entscheiden würdest würdest du keine
lust dazu ab und dem punkt nicht mehr
bestimmten punkt tatsächlich nie mehr
fliegen dürfen sich nicht mehr
fortbewegen
das heißt dass die bestrafung
automatisch drin das system wird massiv
dadurch stabilisiert also ich glaube die
situation der system wird stabilisiert
das kommunistische system wirtschaft
nicht ob stabil bleibt wissen wir nicht
aber es ist die funktion ist ein
programmiert muss man ja sagen dass das
system stabilisiert wird eine
historische gesehen hat ja unterdrückung
von menschen selten auf dauer gut
funktioniert aber ich möchte eine sache
dazu sagen ich finde es also ja ich habe
totale probleme mit diesen diesem regime
war es ihr sehr viel unterdrückt aber
erstens finde ich ein bisschen kurz
betrachtet erst mal also erstmal wenig
schwierig wir werden das jetzt aus
unserer perspektive
china hat eine ganz andere geschichte
und die geschichte da ist tatsächlich
dieses social credit system das ist
nicht neu es war schon immer so dass in
china das total viel ausgemacht hast wie
du dich in der community fragen hast und
die wirklich so punkt systeme hatten wo
du davon profitiert hat und das
übersehen wir hier total deswegen finden
wir schon lesen das eigentlich auch ganz
okay das war mein punkt also wenn ihr
selber wollen können wir da wenig gegen
sagen irgendwie versuchen sie also ich
meine
wir gehen ja auch oft in andere länder
und sagen na ja aber das gibt ja ich sag
mal so es ist halt eine punkten von
dingen drin im negativen die wir in den
negativen pumpen würden wir würden nicht
jemanden der die regierung kritisiert -
punkte geben das ist zum beispiel dann
würde der pluspunkte geht das ist der
punkt es ist problem weil die wir haben
ja auch so ein system das nennt sich ihr
lästern und es nennt sich soziale
kontrolle
wenn ihr nachbar keine ahnung sein kind
schlägt dann werden wir zwar keine
negativpunkte aber irgendwann mal
polizei anrufen der unterschied ist aber
und das habe ich noch gar nicht erwähnt
das funktioniert in china komplett voll
automatisiert und mit hilfe von
künstlicher intelligenz denn überall
gibt es überwachungskameras auf der
straße was auch immer und du wirst die
ganze zeit die texte dein gesicht ist
die ganze zeit im system und du wirst
verfolgt von straße zu straße und wenn
über rot gehst oder wenn du die
straßenseite wechselt also rocking
betreibt was wir in deutschland nicht so
schlimm ist aber in china zum beispiel
nicht erlaubt dass wenn du nicht die
ampel benutzt dann wird das sofort
registriert und du kriegst in diesen
städten wo das halt testweise ausgemacht
wird dann eine sms
hey hier du hast das gar nichts macht
macht das nicht nochmal oder das geht
wenn es dann noch mal machst irgendein
anderer familien freunde und freuen uns
dass alles raus und die kinder mit help
der hier geht mir über rot und macht das
immer mal wieder und wenn es dann häufig
genug magst dann kriegst halte man so
viele negativpunkte lässt du nicht mehr
fliegen darf nicht mehr mobil bist ja
dass wir keine kredite mehr bekommt kann
hausbau anders was auch immer aber in
deutschland gibt es das übrigens auch
schon ein stück weit und zwar bei
krankenkassen
du hast dann nicht die bestrafung du
hast die art belohnung aber ich meine
belohnung ist ja sozusagen für alle die
wir sind nicht gegen eine bestrafung
wenn du deine gesundheitsdaten teilt
sich gut an er ist sportkurse machst und
sowas dann wirst du dafür auch belohnt
muss weniger zahlen die anderen müssen
mehr zahlen
und das funktioniert auch alles über
mathematische modelle es wird und das
ist halt auch bin ich zu dieser punkte
china
klar ist das irgendwie krass wenn ich so
bedroht werde wenn ich irgendwie über
eine rote ampel gehe aber auf der
anderen seite wenn die ampeln schlau
sind und das ein grund hat dass seine
ampel ist dann ist das ja auch wieder
nicht so ganz doof weil wir verhindern
damit dass leute sterben wir werden
dafür sorgen dass unser
gesundheitssystem günstiger wird weil
wir nicht so viele chirurgische
behandlung für autounfälle machen müssen
das ist immer ein abwägen so eine
persönliche freiheit versus gesellschaft
aber ich finde persönlich dass man da
auch das nicht ganz aus dem auge
verlieren darf dass man halt auch nicht
allein auf der welt ist und das ist also
doch kommunistische system
du bist unser kommunist hier ich
persönlich mag noch so einpacken das ist
nicht das ist was ich nicht das ist mir
wurde gesagt dass die farbe ganz kurz
meinen augen wenn die freundin den
kleiderschrank macht ich meine der nasa
dann müssen sie ja ich liebe die farbe
sondern aber das lob seiner police eine
davon wurde von meiner freundin ein
letztes mal wieder dafür dass debatte
rissen sie haupt dass es das hauptthema
freiheit und das bewerten wir hier in
europa höher gegen unfreiheit aber
dienen der gemeinschaft gegen sicherheit
und freiheit würde sich ja man konnte
man mit dem kommunistischen system einer
der sache nicht super witzig finde john
mayer keiner der wirtschaftsgüter der
usa der also die sogenannten turbo
indianer die das sind die die immer
sagen okay wir müssen mehr schulden
aufnehmen um unsere wirtschaft weiter
wachsen zu lassen und das hat er so gar
nicht ganz genau gesagt aber da wird
gern interpretiert und was er gesagt hat
das ist wirklich nachdem wird immer noch
heute wirtschaftspolitik gericht und der
wirtschaft geht es gut durch die der
staat spart der wirtschaft geht es
schlecht die wird die der staat gibt
steuern aus ich sag mal soll er eine
lehre machen sie aber nicht aber sie
sagen immer sie würden zu machen
aber das muss man wissen der john
maynard keynes ist einfach der wird also
nach dem wird gehandelt das muss man
sagt immer genau und er hat eine theorie
aufgestellt dass durch die
technologisierung wir irgendwann in der
lage sein werden für immer mit wir
müssen immer weniger arbeiten kriegen
das gleiche gehalt und haben den
gleichen luxus und meiner meinung nach
stimmt das auch also mich stimmt das
nicht
hatte es stimmt dass das reichen könnte
ja wir werden immer produktiver
das problem ist nur durch unser system
hier
dadurch dass das nicht wirklich
umgesetzt wird dass wir dann weniger
arbeiten heißt das nur dass unsere
arbeit sich verdichtet also ich ihnen
den arzt der vorher kam zehn patienten
am tag hat wer soll und wie plötzlich
hunderte patienten behandeln weil die
technologie mir hilft schneller
irgendwie so ein kernaufgaben berichte
führen und zu was genau und das finde
ich total problematisch weil das zum
einen tritt auf die gesundheit geht da
gibt es eine untersuchung von agentur
für arbeit burnout wird immer weiter
zunehmen durch die verdichtung der
arbeit das ist für uns menschen total
schlecht und es ist nicht nötig und das
ist so das große problem was sich daran
sehe und es passt auch nicht mehr zu den
aufgaben die wir machen müssen also
system zwei dieses glück dass wir ganz
am anfang denkt system 2 das ist halt
viel viel energie aufwendiger und
deswegen ist es sinnvoll dass wir
weniger arbeiten weil wir halt wir
müssen jetzt komplexere sachen machen
können diese einfach in sachen abgeben
das heißt wir haben mehr zeit für uns
und müssen aber auch komplexere aufgaben
und das ist auch anstrengender und
fordernder ist genau jetzt bevor wir zum
von mexiko schwer daran hat das system 2
und warum das durch eine ki
wahrscheinlich eher nicht ersetzt werden
kann
eur klar heutigen stand des wissens muss
man ja auch immer ein chef muss man
definitiv einschränken also system 2 ist
ich handle nicht intuition also nicht
genau mit dem was ich gelernt habe also
das hat fell das hat vier pfoten das ist
wahrscheinlich eine katze sondern ich
denke darüber nach ich versuche
abstrakte gedankengänge zu machen also
zum beispiel versuche ich aus der
umgebung in der ich bin und aus dem ich
muss mal ganz kurz okay
dieses system 2 funktioniert bei jan
koppetsch nicht so super
anlass ist das ding zwar arbeiten ja
okay also ich glaube einfach dass es
eine beispiel ein bisschen zu simpel war
weil das kann man halt auch mit computer
vision machen zum beispiel wenn wir eine
theorie aufstellen wie unser unser oder
was der grund fürs leben person
das ist etwas was eine ki so erst mal
nicht kann weil also was sie machen
können
sie könnte sich alles durchlesen was
dazu mal leute geschrieben haben und
also mittelweg finden
kombinationsmaschine was wir menschen
können wir können sehr gut um den jahre
zusammenhänge übrigen sehen wir ja was
anderes ziel
so wird das aussehen das super toll dass
du dir nicht zum beispiel was dafür
spricht ist hier fraktale hier die band
menge die er irgendwann mal hat das
mathematiker sich mit der integration
beschäftigt also dass man immer die
formel wieder dasselbe ergebnis einsetzt
und da will ich eine immer feinere
dieser kurve bekommt in einer im
koordinatensystem und die hat dann noch
eine bestimmte form
damit hat er erstmal umgerechnet und
dann haben alle gesagt rümmele leute
quatsch und herausgefunden hey alles in
der welt ist fraktal unser unser herz
rhythmus ist fraktal die äste eines
baumes in fraktale also unglaublich viel
dass ein lebensprinzip und das ist
vielleicht zum beispiel dafür
das hätte wahrscheinlich nicht günstige
intelligenz wie solltet ihr darauf
kommen ja du hast also deswegen glaube
ich persönlich dass das der große
unterschied und das ist meiner meinung
nach erst mal was was man nicht kann
also wirklich dieses kreativ sein
irgendwer hat sich mal meinetwegen romeo
und julia ausgedacht und zwar dann wurde
es immer weiter entwickelt eine ki die
kann sich die 20 bücher anschauen und
daraus irgendetwas ja wobei entwickeln
aber das register schaffen an der stelle
habe ich da mal ganz kurz auf meinen
videos verweisen habe ich nicht gemacht
sowohl im juli zu künstlicher
intelligenz die kunst macht ja es gibt
sie nicht doch es gibt total viele
sachen
tolle bilder macht videos es gibt total
viele sachen zweispänner vielleicht kann
man das nicht kurz einblenden wo quasi
der stil eines gemäldes auf ein video
angewendet wird was total schön aussieht
das funktionieren kann und das beispiel
muster und und kontrast erkannt werden
und aus der spd darauf gesetzt wird und
es gibt auch sachen wo quasi eine
komplett neue bilder erschaffen das aber
genau so wie du es gerade gesagt hast
immer nur 1 1 durchschnitt nicht wohin
genau der durchschnitt aber quasi etwas
was innerhalb des rahmens von dem es was
ich hier sowieso schon gelernt hat etwas
neues zu machen etwas mit konventionen
zu brechen was ihr die großen künstler
unsere welt immer getan haben
das kann mit englisch also aber das ist
nichts neues und julia war ja auch
damals was nur jetzt ja da und alle
großen großen bücher die wir jetzt in
deutschland recht lernen oder und ihr
wirklich was was krasses gemacht haben
eine neue epoche gestartet haben waren
als allererstes meistens ein
das ist ja komplett anders oder
teilweise sogar skandalös und das hat
sich mittlerweile immer nur das bekommt
was dem 500 jahre zur forschung gemacht
aber das ist sowieso schon da aber da
könnte sie auch sagen was wir ja zum
beispiel auch auf youtube ständig machen
seit instruktiv macht etwas was ist was
noch niemand gemacht hat versucht alles
verkehrt zu drehen weil ich glaube dann
andererseits roma ist für mich ein super
beispiel wir denken manchmal was wäre
tierisch komplex aber es ist gar nicht
so komplex weil eine geschichte zu
erfinden ist ja einfach nur was hat die
größte fallhöhe ist ein junges paar
verliebt sich und die familien sind
verfeindet ja keine idee natürlich du
brauchst du für eine idee aber ich weiß
ja auch es gibt verfeindete familien ist
gefahren sie verlieben könnte vielleicht
sogar darauf kommen so eine geschichte
mal über das ist das ja nicht was neues
sondern nur versicherungen und julia
erzählt
und ja was das was viele viele filme
heutzutage machen die erzählen immer
dieselbe geschichte miteinander
aber dieses neue element das geht zeigt
damit ich mein bruder dafür gibt es ein
handwerkszeug die pathologie und die
fallhöhe muss möglichst hoch sein vom
tellerwäscher zum millionär und so
weiter so und ich als beispiel sage ich
dann immer die redaktionskonferenz wobei
brainpool tv von stefan raab
das format das wie du turm springt das
tv total turmspringen was da hat einer
gesagt ja wir brauchen wir wieder die
ideen mit einer hohen fallhöhen hat
einer gesagt turmspringen ja wirklich
das zeigt dass ich da etwas ist was
relativ aber es ist total simpel aber
allein nicht machen weil es noch nicht
vorher gemacht wurde das ist der punkt
an die korrelation die fallhöhe und tom
nicht da ist dass man dafür braucht man
schon gerne brüssel und wir müssen
menschen haben angst wenn sie oben auf
dem turm stehen die wollen das nicht da
runter springen wenn sie sich überwinden
müssen ist auch im wahrsten sinne des
wortes fallhöhe der typ der das gesagt
hat standen mal oben auf den 10 die
klinik die weise wenn wir ganz sicher
weiterbringen
also du kannst du nicht bei also wenn du
ihr sagen würdest ok kommen ihre das und
das und das und macht daraus eine
geschichte dann ist das keine chimäre
habe mir das gesagt hat dann muss sich
das in zukunft der kann noch sagen wenn
sie alles wissen der welt sich aneignen
kann wenn wir zum beispiel auch hirn
implantate haben also es gibt ja
inzwischen ist geht ja schon in die
richtung das so ich sag mal
nachvollziehen kann zumindest was da
oben gedacht wird wenn wir das alles
haben wir wirklich darauf zugreifen kann
kann sie das dann nicht vielleicht doch
also wenn sie dann nur unsere idee
heftig gestikulierend warum kann sie
nicht kombinieren gleichen kombiniert
aber es ist halt jemand muss also
kreativität je nach definition
kreativität aber es gibt ja wie gesagt
wird kreativität ist das kombinieren von
wenn ich nämlich genau darum soll das
sind kleinigkeiten kann theoretisch ja
man kann
es gibt aber viele beispiel das gibt
total viele bücher schon die von der ki
generiert wurden
ja und was man da sieht sie kann sätze
schreiben diesen kann man direkt und
vielleicht ist ein abschnitt auch
irgendein thema zu erkennen wo die
nächsten fünf sätze und das kann sich
natürlich auf touren aber du von anfang
bis ende das ist so wird
das ist die versteht so große distanzen
nicht mehr dass ein charakter zum
beispiel eine story akteur ich mache und
sich verändern so will aber ich mache
also technisch gesehen spricht nichts
dagegen sind aktuell noch nicht aber
weil das geht als vor drei tagen noch
ein artikel gesehen
über diese neue ki die gruselig exakte
texte schreiben können wir über alles so
also du die wurde trainiert mit
zusammenhängen wo es halt also man geht
dann hin und schaut euch einfach den
zusammenhang von wörtern haben sondern
von satzstrukturen und so da sind die
schon dabei aber wie gesagt das ist
trotzdem immer nur eine korrelation
zwischen der das ist schon gut aber dann
wenn du sagst dann immer ja die kann das
so gut aber das handy korrelation dann
ist er wieder die umkehr frage ist die
korrelation in den großteil davon schon
einigen fällen aber nicht geht also nur
das ganz neue schulden würde aber das
ist normal
das wäre ja mal in den kommentaren
diskutiert ich werde da sein und wer
richtig richtig heftig meine meinung wir
werden es ja nicht wir werden sich gern
können wir sind ja ja offensichtlich ist
das ja wirklich eine total schwierige
frage sind wir so einfach
vielleicht sind wir so einfach wie wir
unsere key später mal als komplexes
vorstellen oder ist die ki oder sind
wird kann die ki so komplexe npd und
sind wir komplexe das sind ja die ist ja
sag mal sind die beiden pole dessen oder
wird dieser unterschied immer bleiben
wird die bestimmte dinge nie können die
wir können weil hier so toll sind und
ich werde jetzt wahrscheinlich
beantworten können aber wisst ihr was
ich mich frage wo hört uns kann ich
eigentlich umbringt also ich mach ja
gesagt werden mordende getriebene
roboter über die straße laufen uns alle
umbringen weil wir mit magneten kaputt
markt ich sage mal so wenn es uns alle
nicht geben würde hätten wir kein co2
probleme ja so wenn du das zulässt im
endeffekt k s und das darf man nicht
vergessen sind von uns menschen
programmierten und wenn
wie zum beispiel zulassen dass es eine
gibt ohne ausschalter könnte es sein und
die irgendwie so ein selbstbestimmter
instinkt hat und keine ahnung was dann
könnte das theoretisch seien aber am
ende des tages ist halt die frage ob die
sowas programmieren würden also das
lustig ist es gibt ja ein beispiel
glaube ich auch bei google da haben die
zwei chaos programmiert die sich
miteinander unterhalten haben und
irgendwann haben sie leider überhaupt
nichts mehr damit anfangen die haben
eine eigene sprache entwickelt und sich
unterhalten tatsächlich aber sie hat es
hat kein außenstehender mehr verstanden
diese dienst hätten theoretisch den
massenmord der welt planen können wir
hätten es nicht mal gemerkt weil sie
sich in einer sprache unterhalten haben
die wir nicht verstanden haben und wie
werden sie auch irgendwo raus bekommen
dann weiß ich nicht sie haben sie auch
dann einfach abgeschaltet
das ist sehr gut wir können den stecker
ziehen ist ja wahr an eine zukünftige
carini auf roboter zum beispiel zu
gefallen dass sie mich lieber antwort
auf die frage wie kommt sie aus dem
labor das verhindern
das ist aber auch also das wäre ja was
was wir gebaut hätten und ich glaube
persönlich also die gefahr geht nicht so
sehr von der kg aus sondern von uns
menschen der vorteil einer carey ist
also einer der großen vorteil die ich
zum beispiel daran sehe es das vanity
und zum kampfgebiet geschickt wird und
es geht darum irgendwie kann terroristen
oder manchmal nichts zu suchen
der ki ist das erste mal scheißegal ob
damit waffen auf die gezeigt wird mensch
der reagiert und eine waffe ich
erschieße das war ein kind was man stock
erhalten hat es irgendwie also das ist
krass und das passiert also ich glaube
ein großteil der als ich glaube dass das
schon was ist was nicht so ganz selten
vorkommt und eine kann in dem sinne da
oder ein roboter kann indem denn da viel
cooler bleiben und keine chance würde er
geht kaputt gemacht und deshalb
geschützt was weiß ich so das ist finde
ich die positive seite bei der ganzen
geschichte
die negative seite ist natürlich dass
wir da einfach wieder ungleichheiten
haben also aber das ist halt dass die
atombombe war spätestens der punkt wo
einige länder gegen die usa oder so
keine chance mehr haben aber nicht
verschließen kann ich glaube
wo ich wirklich gefährlich ist es nicht
dass sie aktiv wird und der overlord
wird und uns alle in die fast kraft
sondern dass wir menschen zu sehr
vertrauen und nicht mehr hinterfragen
was eigentlich entschieden wird ja aber
das ist jetzt die youtuber algorithmus
wenn wir wir werden nicht wissen wie
dieses video ihrer performance das kann
super performance kann nicht so gut
beworben ich immer das sagen das wird
nicht so gut bei folgen weil wir die
wörter
er hat das alles mit ok es ist gibt es
gibt ja wirklich ein paar gute beispiele
dafür nannte das hast du gesagt hast nur
die züge werden anhand der schienen
erkannt und genauso gibt es beispiele
dafür wo thema rassismus ist wie sie
wissen hat sich gerade video zum thema
rassismus künstliche intelligenz ging um
krankenkassen algorithmus wo schwarze
patienten einfach schlechter behandelt
wurden als weise genommen
und genau das ist ihr das problem die
menschen vertrauen an einer technologie
die wir selber erschaffen haben das ist
am ende des tages ein werkzeug und
lassen ihren laufen hinterfragen die
entscheidung nicht mehr und fragen uns
vor allem nicht wie ist es zu dieser
entscheidung gekommen
denn statistisch gesehen mag das in 50
prozent der fälle richtig sein was man
kann hier entscheidet aber wenn man sich
dann land verlangen guckt kann das
teilweise seien oder waren schienen im
bild es war ein zug nach was war
überhaupt kein druck sondern irgendein
komplett
trotzdem aber wenn man ihr habt die
beispiele atombombe genannt ist es sehr
theoretisch vorstellbar dass ein mensch
mit dieser technologie so schlecht
umgeht sie auch gentechnik und so würden
gerade irgendwo welche fliegen rom wo
sie sich diese ausgesetzt haben in
südamerika also gibt ja oft beispiel du
willst du bestimmte suchergebnis auch
beim zug passiert es ja auch und stadt
dass die mehr bieten mehr friedlicher
sind um nicht geben sind sie aggressiver
und geben weniger wohl nicht zum
beispiel
und das kann ja auch mal dass du einfach
eben das als forscher nicht überblickt
und den einen ausschalter hat vergisst
weil du denkst du bist ja so haben den
kommandos lang ist ja auch noch mal um
dieses thema autonomes fahren
autonomes fahren wird zu weniger opfern
im straßenverkehr führen aber es wird
opfer geben dann kam ein riesiges
ethisches problem wie entscheidet die ki
in dem fall wäre tot gefahren
lebt der fahrer oder der fußgänger je
nachdem was die konsequenzen sind wir
wissen generell ist es sicherer aber im
einzelfall haben ein riesiges ethisches
problem und bei der ki kommen noch dazu
wenn sie eben weltumspannend oder groß
ist und nicht nur auf ein auto
beschränkt das eben in der
vergesslichkeit solche entscheidung
trifft sondern eben eine generelle
entscheidung wie kriegen wir das co2
problem in den griff ob sich heute nicht
darf doch zum schluss kommt uns alle
umzubringen war das einfach die
einfachste und beste lösung ist oder
sollte es schon jemanden der das
auslösen
aber das ist ja auch sagen okay ich
persönlich finde es gibt viele menschen
auf der welt ich zünde eine atombombe
und löse so dass man sagen kann bisher
noch kein wenig gemacht zum glück genau
aber ich habe dann vielleicht wollen was
ja und ich vielleicht passiert es nicht
weil der mensch immer diese würde hut
nehmen massenmord mache ich nicht frei
hitler im aber der hat ja auch langsam
eskaliert der hätte wahrscheinlich auch
nicht ein atom und mal wobei der etwas
oktober geschmissen
aber das zeigt was die verrückten immer
gibt ja gut aber das ändert also die ki
ist ja am ende auch nur eines dieser
werkzeuge die der verrückte auslöst und
ob die jetzt also kann ich glaube nicht
dass es das im großen unterschied macht
ich glaube ich glaub seinem samt punkt
ist der verrückte hat halt so groß auf
laptop und internet und kann die partie
selber programmieren
du kommst atombombe als normaler
millionen brz kenntnis so die leute am
morgen zehn ständen youtube ein video
gemacht das heißt dass man oder der
erzählt wie man zehn minuten der ki
selbst programmieren kann und ich habe
so fünf minuten aber damit kann man
keine menschen töten richtig was habe
ich glaube persönlich also das wirklich
diese gefahren diese bilder mit waffen
das ist bullshit das okay ist nicht das
was gefällt das einzige was wirklich
gefährlich ist und das ist ein problem
das ist die beeinflussung durch
künstliche intelligenz die und alina
lotz und so war das ja ja das ist halt
nicht dieses bild okay ich hab ne ki die
die hat werbung und die wird uns
schießen oder so sondern das problem ist
eher dass micky und aufstachelt und wir
uns gegenseitig umbringen weil wir so
beeinflusst werden genau das ist nämlich
noch mal ein super meinung
auf dem world von tears forum und da
ging es auch um dieses thema und dann
kamen ein beispiel najin ist dieses ich
schubse leute darin sich besser zu
verhalten
aber ich kann sie halt auch ist es
letztlich manipulation bin ich dem keine
ahnung dem esel möhre hin vorhalte dann
wolf steht er hinterher und wir machen
was eben auch und wir können theoretisch
auch gemacht werden um was kommt was
schlimmes zu tun
wir können den abschneiden der plastik
zu verbrauch und in dem keine ahnung
alle produkte billiger sind mit basti
wir können zu einem möglichen verführt
werden so konnten wir schon immer sagen
erwärmung das ist was werbung ist das
auch wahlkampfwerbung ist und so was
aber das wird immer effektiver als
meinen wir beide machen nächster woche
ein video dazu dass heiko logical
targeting immer heute sonntag das geht
dann freitag also dem es wird drinnen
glauben hier abonnieren und werdet ihr
das sehen sind so spannendes interview
geführt mit einer professorin aus new
york die unter anderem zu diesem
facebook cambridge analytiker was
gemacht hat nämlich nicht funktioniert
das dass sich der algorithmus von
facebook so genau kennt was man weiß wie
kann man quasi werbung zu dieser cajun
so dass nur quasi dadurch dann
aufgebracht wird oder ein bestimmtes
produkt bekommt oder halt eben donald
trump willst also da werden weil sie die
leute tage denn von dem man weiss ja ich
glaube schon immer damen da ist
irgendwas schief gelaufen und dann kommt
die werbung sagt übrigens du hast du
recht gehabt da ist was schief gelaufen
deswegen und da ist auch bei ihm das ist
auch das wahrscheinlich größte problem
die menschen des einsetzens ist ein
werkzeug ich dieses böse sondern der
mensch der sich einsetzt und somit
böswilliger absicht und das ist
eigentlich noch viel krasser als das
wird nicht geschaut okay du bist
programm christ jetzt die werbung
sondern du bist so ein psychologischer
charakter mit der und der art der
werbung kann ich dich am besten dafür
überzeugen und ihren studien dazu
gemacht die gezeigt haben
das funktioniert schnell mal ein stalin
oder einen hitler im besitz von
günstiger intelligenz wahrscheinlichkeit
an dass das eine sehr komplexe frage ich
meine ganz ehrlich also ich glaube dass
hitler schon so mithalten konnte was die
beeinflussung angeht
ich weiß nicht ob das mittel das thema
eben keine ahnung aber nochmal
zurückzukommen
sie haben nicht versucht hillary wähler
umzustimmen ja so macht wie genommen die
noch keine meinung hat nun vor einem
krieg war schwachsinn psychologisch
etwas zu verlieren hatten die angst
hatten und haben doch diese angst
gesetzt die haben den leuten angst
gemacht und gesagt hier
donald trump hat die lösung dafür der
baut die mauer er hält den ganzen
ausländern die bösen alle raus
der hintergedanke und das ist doch
wirklich eigentlich das kräftige dazu
auch also meiner meinung nach sind die
medien dann noch viel schlimmer aber das
ist also in den usa ist das glaube ich
wirklich extrem
und das hat dann nichts mit geld zu tun
sondern einfach das sind leute die sehr
sehr gut medial irgendwas aufbereiten
können und leute in eine richtung lenken
also dazu darf man nicht vergessen dass
es und das ist wirklich ganz schlimm um
das so war es gibt einen medienkonzern
was machen was man zwei oder drei
familien die komplette usa medien
ungefähr ja aber man kann also im
englischsprachigen raum das ist
eigentlich nur robert murdoch der diese
der meinung in großbritannien und in
amerika komplett im griff hat der ist
der er herausgeber der wichtigsten
zeitungen und fernsehsender in beiden
den wichtigsten englischsprachigen
ländern wo es im moment relativ
friedlichen komisch woran liegt das wohl
und dessen drei familien das ist auf
jeden fall dass blumberg nicht auch die
blumen könnte sein und die dritte dörner
ted turner
wenn ich mir ja ich weiß nicht ich muss
eine sache kann ich lange nicht so
stehen lassen müssen leider fünf von uns
ging es gut von hinten war selbst waren
autos gesprochen und diese dieses
klassische dilemma zwischen fahre ich
jetzt die alte oma tod und fünf kleine
ländern gehen wir doch mal rein
das passiert so eine realität nicht und
ich finde es sogar schädlich das so
darzustellen dass das quasi die aufgabe
ist in der realität werden als
sogenannte garniert das kann der sein
also du hast sie möglichkeit du hast von
der oma du musst dir ausweisen
du musst dich entscheiden vielleicht mit
mehr geht ist ich weiß es ist ein
sonderfall aber der existiert wenn du
eine milliarde kilometer im jahr fährt
so was natürlich irgendwann mal
passieren auf jeden fall aber in der
realität werden da es nicht so
programmiert so zu entscheiden dürfen
sich in deutschland momentan ist und ist
es viel wichtiger hand die frage zu
stellen ist es vielleicht besser wenn
wir wasser weil du gesagt hast es werden
menschen sterben du ja durch selbst
fahren autos aber so in der sekunde in
der es weniger werden als menschliche
fahrer sollten da einem switch und
natürlich das problem ist dass es werden
ganz andere situationen gekommen wo
menschen sterben wo man sagen würde
und das würde den menschen hier nicht
passieren und dann wird es richtig
unangenehm wenn die ki vielleicht zum
beispiel da war es schon passiert das
ist realer fall huber auto hatten eine
frau tot gefahren das war sie haben den
menschen gibt aber auch etwas wären drin
hat auch die handy geguckt wenn menschen
mir sehr wichtig gewesen dass da jemand
dass da jemand ist da die quali hat
zwischen fahrrad und fußgängerin nicht
unterscheiden weil die hat ihr fahrrad
geschoben hat sie komplett tot gefahren
wären die menschen nicht passiert du
kannst du argumentieren der mensch hätte
an anderer stelle die frage macht auf
dieselben gefahrenen kilometer und
deswegen was eigentlich besser dann zwei
autos zu schützen
deswegen habe ich ihr gesagt wie aus der
sachschaden wird es weniger tote wichtig
aber wir als gesellschaft werden dass
höchstwahrscheinlich nicht in der
sekunde zu lassen wurde selbst fahren
autos auch einen tick sicherer sind weil
leute lieber sagen ich will selber die
kontrolle haben ich will dass ich will
am steuer sitzen
und dann wird irgendeine punkt kommen wo
eben genau diese leute davon abgehalten
werden müssen selber zu fahren weil es
gefährlich ist dann müssen wir das
selber fahren von menschen verbieten ja
aber wird hass durchkommen würden wir
dass ich gleich welche regierung sitzen
also die länder dazu muss man ja sagen
die ersten tester fahrer schlafend am
steuer ein auf der autobahn also die
finden dass da die so schlecht wenn
ihnen das fahren abgenommen wird
ich glaube die entwicklung wird dahin
laufen also die wird da glaube ich bin
ich seit jahren welche regierung
es ist natürlich befremdlich war das
tempolimit ich wollte sagen ist
befremdlich ist es gibt ein tempolimit
in deutschland gibt das ist tragisch ist
man sagen ja aber eigentlich muss es
also ich sag mal die logik führt dahin
dass selbst fahren in zukunft verboten
wird weil wir menschen fehlt fehlbarer
sind als autonomes vater wir haben
gebeten dass wir uns fragen zu schicken
und tatsächlich um das super viele leute
gemacht und nie werden wir zu
beantworten
okay was sollen wir zum thema machen
eine frage die ich ziemlich gut finde
ist von philipp otto steht das thema so
schwierig diesen haben ok einträchtig
ziemlich cool fallen dann ist von einem
philipp otto 15
welche jobs in klammern hochqualifiziert
fallen wahrscheinlich weg viel anwälte
habe ich schon mal besser als anwälte
also dieses man muss eingesetzt werden
oder ein präzedenzfall der irgendwo
anders schon mal gedacht dass du musst
30 jahre bücher durchwühlen kann ich
viel besser
es gibt dazu ein richtig interessantes
paper von osborne und frei die erstmal
die hauptaussage die in den medien um
aufgenommen wird 47 prozent der jobs in
den usa werden durch keller ersetzt
werden ziemlich düsteres bild könnte man
sagen und dann haben sie geschrieben was
kann nicht ersetzt werden das am
leichtesten ersetzt werden kann sind
routine jobs da wundern buchhalter
aufgeführt was noch genau
fließbandarbeit nummer 2 was nicht so
gut ersetzt werden kann
interessanterweise treckerfahrer kellner
und weil ein gericht wird nicht ersetzt
ich glaube also ich meine rein technisch
wäre das schon möglich aber das will
halt keiner möchte die soziale
interaktion haben und ganz interessant
job nummer drei sind ärzte und
rechtsanwälte und journalisten
und das war nicht so super interessant
weil man da wunderbar sehen können wie
unfassbar wenige diese leute vom thema
künstliche intelligenz haben hier wir
haben
k s die besser krankheitsbilder erkennen
können als menschen als ärzte wir haben
hier in berlin bin ich mir ganz sicher
dass ein start up ist was sich darauf
spezialisiert hat mit künstlicher
intelligenz rechtsfälle zu bewerten und
damit zu entscheiden welche sie annehmen
oder welche nicht das heißt also die
jobs wo die gesagt haben
die sind am schwersten zu ersetzen sind
meiner meinung nach fast am leichtesten
zu ersetzen
die frage ist nur ob der wille da genau
und erlösten ist super interessant die
washington post hat bei den olympischen
spielen in rio mein ich also auf jeden
fall bei olympischen spielen ich glaube
in rio ihre facebook borussia die
berichterstattung über diese themen von
nackig schreiben lassen nun echt und das
hat man wusste man nicht bevor die das
irgendwann raus gegeben haben und der
einfache grund ist dass die jedes jahr
hunderte journalisten dahin geschickt
haben damit die einfach die ganzen
ergebnisse notieren von den spielen und
so und jetzt hat sich herausgestellt
dass es einfach viel einfacher für die
iss und am ende genauso gut funktioniert
muss man dazu sagen das ist natürlich
auch routinearbeiten also wo ich schon
gesagt habe anwälte das ist ja
eigentlich eher die assistenz arbeit bei
den glauben und das hier so also es gibt
auch jede zeitschrift hat zum beispiel
wetterbericht und den aktienmarkt um 9
uhr ist es am hochberg und alles schon
von karten geschrieben
aber das sind ja so so kleinigkeiten die
wirklich coolen und wichtigen pieces die
journalistische arbeit oder die die die
im
im saal stehen vor dem richter stehen
und ein wichtiges statement abzugeben
das sind doch alles sachen die wir
menschen auch weiterhin machen müssen
genau aber es würde hast also ich glaube
das ist nicht so ganz kleiner teil ist
also glaube ich weiß nicht ich denke
nicht dass anwälte ein großteil des
tages im gerichtssaal stehen sondern
großteil des tages kreativ ich sage mal
ein lernprozess zu interagieren zu
bewerten was der andere gerade für eine
strategie fährt und wo du ihn packen
kannst ich glaube das kann ein mensch
nicht oder bei uns soweit ich sage immer
so dass keiner kann ihn nicht und kanada
ähnlich soziale menge sag ich mal die
sind sozial das müssen menschen machen
weil das ist sozialer interaktion eine
ki kann mit sicherheit unsere texte
schreiben aber zum beispiel das was wir
jetzt hier diskutiert haben soll dass er
kein können also die festhalle
diskutiert ob es geht um
missverständnisse dabei auch um
korrekturen um meinungen um so viele
dinge das kann kein ich oder auch selbst
bei mir das sind ja nachrichten dass er
konnte wie vielleicht sogar die texte
schreiben was er gesagt es gibt
inzwischen aber sie der journalist
ordnet ja ein und zwar in einen riesigen
gesamtzusammenhang dazu gehört das dazu
gehört dass er sich jahrelang damit ja
beschäftigt hat und das auch
interpretiert wenn ich nur sagt es gibt
schon fünf studien dazu und die haben
das und das und das gesagt sondern da
gibt es fünf studien dazu drei davon
halte ich nicht für glaubwürdig ich habe
auch gute gründe
zwei davon gehen aber in dieselbe
richtung oder haben eine andere
orientierung oder sonst was ich habe es
gibt so oft texte die einfach erstens
ist nicht richtig einordnen zweitens
auch riesen fehler machen selbst im
spiegel bei der dpa und sonstwo einfach
irgendjemanden was gar nicht verstanden
hat und mit der einordnung dass man zum
beispiel wer weiß dass es wie in
referenz ferro meter mit denen die
gravitationswellen bestimmt werden
funktioniert und das ist noch im
interferenz perimeter in hannover gibt
womit man das holografische und manchmal
schon gravitationswellen gesucht hat wo
man aber auch und grafischen universum
gesucht hat das dann die nochmal
interferenz thermometer in den usa
gebaut haben vermieters heißt das wo sie
nur dass damit untersuchen
diese zusammenhänge das kann mitteilte
ich glaube die heute die kann das alles
finden aber das zu gewichten zum
gewichten gehört glaube ich noch viel
viel mehr
ich glaube es ist also ich denke dass
das nicht unterstützen schon sehr
wichtig sein kann weil es einfach in der
lage ist halt tatsächlich viel mehr dazu
wissen im irakkrieg und ja ich glaube
dass und das ist ein interessanter punkt
du hast immer noch dieses menschliche
element am ende was dieses system 2 ist
genau wie ist das wirklich logisch und
man spricht zwar auch immer vom
programmieren von logik ich finde das
ist halt okay das ist ist eine andere
form der logik als diese menschliche
logik die also ein bisschen
selbstkritischer ist also das ist es mal
zusammenfassen ich würde sagen was
passieren wird es werden auf jeden fall
hoch qualifizierte jobs die ärzte
rechtsanwälte verdichtet werden
reduziert werden in dem sinne dass ein
anwalt viel mehr klienten gleichzeitig
betreuen kann
von ak assistenz genau mit hilfe von akg
assistenz was aber nicht passieren wird
ist dass der job komplett ausgerottet
wird und was ich auch richtig finde zu
sagen ich glaube auch dass die jobs wie
trucker oder buchhalter oder so dass die
auch weiterhin existieren werden die
werden nur nicht mehr dieses ich trage
jetzt wie viel stunden hat eine person
im monat gearbeitet in der liste ein
sondern die werden er sein okay hier hat
unsere kein problem weil dass sie
überfordert da springe ich jetzt ein das
heißt wir werden die arbeit wird sich
verlagern aber es wird nicht so sein
dass hochqualifizierte jobs in massen
wegfallen und das ist auch das was ganz
viele andere studien gezeigt haben also
find osbourne diese studie wurde
ziemlich die ist zwar extrem oft in den
medien zitiert worden aber in der
wissenschaftswelt wohl wie zerrissen
weil die halt wirklich super seltsamen
namen hat
und viel zu also man sieht die wollten
an dem bild zeichnen was gut in den
medien funktioniert hat ja funktioniert
ich habe eine frage hier auf dem
communiqué von pixum von casilas lwk das
geht noch mal ein bisschen weiter mit
unserer frage wird die sich ergänzt uns
umbringen
stephen hawking stellte sinngemäß die
these auf dass es in der natur einer
intelligenten intelligente spezies lege
sich selber zu vernichten
denn für die mal wie alle kulturen haben
sie am schluss vernichtet das muss man
dann zu sehen um sie als theken die
ägypter oder sonst was machen die sind
nicht nur vernichtet worden habe ich
auch selber vernichtet also gut was
haltet ihr von dieser theorien auf
welche art könnte das aufeinandertreffen
und zusammenleben von menschen und
künstlicher intelligenz diese theorie
stützen entkräften oder beeinflussen
oder vielleicht ist so wie ich jetzt den
zug ins gegenteil verkehren glaube ich
tatsächlich ist das historische gesehen
ja und es gibt auch mal wieder
je nachdem jemals leuten möchte relativ
viele hinweise die aktuell darauf
hindeuten dass wir in so eine richtung
bewegen
demokratisch aufwand ausruhen zb ist
immer so ein schönes beispiel und also
an der stelle wo space expand deswegen
der grund warum wir zu mast in den mars
besiedeln sollten um ein backup der
menschheit zu haben ob er ein zweites um
ein zweites system zu haben wenn wir
hier scheiße bauen dass wir da immer
noch menschen haben die weitermachen
können aber es ist auch super schwierig
sich vorzustellen also wenn jetzt nach
draußen gut 20 letzten 10 20 jahren
alles getan hat und als 120 jahren von
vor 20 jahren noch nicht fliegen dann
waren die 50 jahre später auf dem mond
und was wir jetzt alles machen können
ist unglaublich und lassen sich jetzt
vorzustellen dass wir das alles
hinschmeißen und selber ausrotten
aber das ist man also sie klimawandel es
war ganz oft so osterinseln zum beispiel
dass sich eine kultur die natürlichen
ressourcen zerstört hat und dann
eingegangen ist das ist ganz oft
passiert aber da wir machen es jetzt
weltweit harari modus ist ein buch was
ich genau mit der frage beschäftigt und
was das interessant ist wir waren bis
jetzt noch nie in einer phase
wo wir eigentlich in der lage gewesen
werden uns alle alle menschen auf der
welt zu versorgen
vor vielen krankheiten zu schützen gegen
epidemien vorzugehen und in der lage
sind wir jetzt der einzige wohnbau
momentan noch so viele menschen sterben
auf der welt ist dass wir menschen
kriege anzetteln dass wir mit
lebensmitteln handeln so als werden dass
werden werden dass aktien und dann damit
die lebensgrundlage für leute nehmen wir
mal rein von den ressourcen her und rein
von der technologie her wären wir schon
in der lage dazu und zwar es gäbe auch
also das phänomen überbevölkerung und
gibt es eigentlich gar nicht es ist eine
unterversorgung er also ja es gibt halt
im endeffekt man sieht das ja immer bei
dieser wachstumskurve jetzt nach dem
krieg hat einen starken anstieg
aber wenn eine gesellschaft besser
gebildet ist
höhere standards hat dann kommt das
irgendwann zum erliegen das wachstum ihr
und in den westlichen in den westlichen
ländern
man schwelgt gott dass er wahrscheinlich
schwierig zu sagen nee aber in den
westlichen ländern da ist das schon
passiert und jetzt ist es halt also
momentan deshalb eines der probleme dass
es in afrika momentan noch nicht so weit
ist aber das würde irgendwann auch
wahrscheinlich zum punkt kommen wo es
halt nicht mehr weiter wächst und wir
sind das ist auf jeden fall in dem
rahmen den wir versorgen können das
große problem ist nur wir müssen halt
wir dürfen uns nicht gegenseitig
umbringen weil wir uns so auch staffeln
und so und ich glaube persönlich dass
dani zum beispiel insofern schon super
hilfreich sein kann weil übersetzung
also ein ernstes problem zwischen
verschiedenen ländern ist wir können
nicht miteinander reden kann ich aber
plötzlich verstehen was die leute da
sagen und dass die leute gar nicht so
schlimm sind wie uns die medien das
sagen
dann wird das wahrscheinlich dazu führen
dass weniger konflikt und solange kein
krieg ich glaube das hat mir noch nie
also es ist die zeit wird immer so
schlecht inhalt und das ist meiner
meinung nach das große problem der
medien das sucht dann wird als wir sind
immer immer kurz vorm kollaps aber dass
das stimmt einfach nicht
es gibt dinge die müssen verbessert
werden das ist wichtig dass man das
anspricht aber es ist nicht so dass wir
eine super super schlimme zeit haben uns
geht es wirklich sehr sehr gut
weißt du was das letzte video war er
sich bei
watts angemacht habe auf seinem kanal
wie man die welt retten kann und es ging
darum wie man im partie schafft wie man
es schafft dass ich in die in die schuhe
von jemand anderem versetzt zum beispiel
halten ein hungerndes kind in afrika und
das virtual reality is halt einen
einjährigen quasi mitten in einer doku
wo man wirklich sehen kann wie diese wie
man erlebt und die umstände sind und ich
glaube das ist ein großer punkt um sich
halt nicht gegenseitig aufzustacheln und
immer von wir und die zu denken sollen
wir sind alle bürger der welt und will
im all auf dem planeten
wir hatten ein riesen riesenglück dass
wir hier geboren wurden andere menschen
haben es nicht so gut und deswegen
sollten sie nicht verteufeln
ja und ich glaube man muss das halt auch
einfach rational sehen also diese
emotionale sache die finde ich auch mal
schön aber ich finde man kann sie auch
einfach rational betrachten und sich
anschauen okay was für technologien
haben wir was für ein lebensmittel
überschuss haben wir wie viele menschen
sind wir okay wir könnten uns versorgen
gebrauchten bräuchten gar keine kriege
führen wir müssten nicht in syrien die
ölquellen schützen was so funktioniert
politik nicht so viele entscheidungen
einstellen funktioniert immer
und deswegen muss man menschen
ansprechen und filme machen und
journalistische arbeit machen die leute
hat auch gefühlsmäßig an spricht also
dafür mächtig einer tour zurück frage
ist das überall so wir haben freunde
über das beispiel china gesprochen was
ich eigentlich für einen staat halte der
sehr viel auch für seine eigenen
bewohner macht ist dass da auch so dass
es nicht rational gefällt wird
die entscheidung die man ja unglaublich
viel propaganda zum beispiel ein kind
jetzt zwei können politik es gibt eine
menge werbespots graffiti auf den wänden
soziale sozialen druck der der sagt hey
du hast jetzt zwei kinder hat zwei
kinder zu haben nicht mehr
früher war es halt ein kind dafür ist
einmal die preise die umsetzung geht die
entscheidung da vor ort meiner meinung
nach ist wirklich sehr sehr rational
also ich finde es gibt wenig länder die
so rational sind und auch so rational
sein können wie china und das ist von
außen unfassbar wuselig weil wir halt
sehr emotional geprägt sind aber ich
finde china zum beispiel das ist ein
land was extrem schnell gewachsen ist
was auch viele dinge wirklich also was
die zum beispiel
für sozialen wohnungsbau haben und so
weiß das ist was was wir in deutschland
können davon träumen sozialen
wohnungsbaus bei uns rückläufig bei
denen die haben so viel geld dass die in
der lage sind da neue sachen zu bauen
und zwar auch wirklich gut wirklich eher
ressourcen sparend und energie
freundlich und das ist glaube ich das
was man oft nicht sieht und wo ich sagen
würde das ist sehr sehr rational
transportmittel auch aber ich wusste
standpunkt dass die politik hat rational
denken und die entscheidung hat sich
dass es möglich ist rational es ist
möglich rationale entscheidungen zu
treffen
wir haben es noch nicht so hier im
westen genau weil wir halt unsere
politiker wählen und diese diese wahl
wird emotional entschieden
donald trump hat geworden weil alle
angst hatten davor hatten wir schon
gesprochen
hey das ist das bessere system ein
diktatorisches system professional
entschieden wer das beste system ist das
system war halt ein eine entität alles
entscheiden kann wenn sie das beste im
sinn hat ja funktioniert wurde können
sie erkennen kann oder dass man diese
entscheidungen wie zum beispiel wahlen
halt rationaler trifft und das ist die
aufgabe der medien und den mussten die
eigentlich nachkommen also nicht zu dem
da muss ich wieder den youtube cottbus
vor tschechien gesteuert du hast nur mit
emotional starken themen erfolg das im
video muss die emotionen ansprechen der
titel muss die emotionen ansprechen wenn
du das nicht machen würde würden dann
videos nicht funktionieren würde uns
karriere wahrscheinlich dass wir die so
nennt hast du was total zieht sich wie
ein roter faden durch diese dann direkt
interessieren na ja da muss ich
vielleicht umbringen oder keine ahnung
ist kein gefährlich oder
lebensgefährliche 2 nochmal noch eine
nutzer frage ich mal wir sind über die
chancen hatten uns das schneiden soll
übrigens sehr wird sich das jemand
angesprochen hatte was der typ im
hintergrund macht der typ das war tektas
tisch und also irgendwann hatte ich
vorgeschlagen das ist doch super witzig
wäre wenn er hinten durchs bild läuft
hat er festgestellt
ja aber wenn ich da hinten durchlaufen
dann sieht man mich ja nur von hinten
dann beschlossen dass er einfach
irgendwer
eigentlich ganz witzig aber es habe auch
gestern auf dem world von tears forum
auch ein video dazu
wie gesagt aber online machen eine
playlist mit 14 videos können alle
anschauen
heute kann er nicht einmal sagen aber es
macht so alles sind auch das text hectas
tisch rückwärts läuft ich habe den
kommentaren gefunden worden es ist dass
jemand der mission der stadt geschrieben
hat der super coole kommentare macht und
das möchte ich mal an die community
zurückgeben vielen vielen dank dafür
finde ich total geil weil also gerade
bei instagram kann ich so cool weil du
dann persönliche nachrichten christi
manchmal so inhalts vor sinne das ist
wirklich total geil so vielen dank und
geschrieben hat eltern durch erika durch
was wenn sich dies nicht an die asi
motion gesetze halten oder diese
missinterpretiert kurzer crashkurs was
nicht immer von gesetze das neue gesetz
ist quasi das oberster bei einen roboter
oder eine ki darf nicht den menschheit
schaden oder durch nichthandeln zulassen
dass der menschheit irgendetwas passiert
das erste gesetz ist es darf einen
menschen nicht schaden töten was auch
immer es sei denn das korreliert mit dem
spricht gegen das gesetz das zweite ist
muss befehle folgen muss befehlen folge
nicht sein dass man spricht den ersten
oder der nullten setzt also ich darf
jetzt da kann ich nicht sagen dass es
mit der christoph umbringen sollen und
dass letztlich jetzt ist der roboter
oder die karte muss sich selber erhalten
es sei denn das widerspricht den
vorherigen besetzen also ein roboter
kann sich opfern um einen menschenleben
zu retten macht ja auch sehr viel sie
wie zum beispiel im film award gezeigt
ja da gibt es auch sehr stark um die
maximal schon gesetze und da wurde dann
auch 50 entscheidung getroffen hätte ich
das sechsjährige mädchen oder hätte ich
den 40 jährigen mann
und dann gab es da noch die
wahrscheinlichkeit mit
überlebenswahrscheinlichkeit und sowas
finde ich immer noch sehr aktiv ics
beispiel aber das eigentliche frage war
jetzt was mit den anderen gesetzen was
ist wenn sich die ki nicht daran hält
das problem auch das finde ich einfach
sehr konstruiert man kann ja nicht mehr
sagen wenn du einen menschen schaden
würde ist dann macht das nicht so
funktioniert hat programmieren nicht du
kannst du selbst besitze kannst du ja
nicht ganz hart rein kommt es gibt immer
interpretationsspielraum
du kannst schon sagen
also es gibt halt so diese diese
hintertüren offen lässt von wegen okay
normalerweise erfolgt so wieder in den
politischen einschätzungen was zu tun
ist
seinen das und das und das gilt das
könntest du schon hart da rein schreiben
das problem ist natürlich nur woher weiß
ich ich schade gleich eine menschen also
bei ansagen geht das so bei autos zum
beispiel das wird dann aber eine
rechtliche frage und ich weiß nicht mal
mit herrn soll merkel ein video dazu
gemacht dass wenn ein auto dicht
auffährt
das ist extrem komplex und es ist
tatsächlich bis jetzt auch sehr
unbefriedigend gelöst wobei das wie in
witzige ist ja und da ist die politik
übrigens war ihrer zeit voraus es gibt
schon rahmenbedingungen unter denen ki
und roboter in zukunft in der eu
eingesetzt werden dürfen weil das
durchaus als problem gesehen so zu
einigen der gentechnik gibt ja auch
rahmenbedingungen und da hat man sich
schon gedanken darum gemacht und ist
wahrscheinlich auch nicht ganz schlecht
du hast du also das ist so ein super
komplexes thema finde ich was einfach
daran liegt dass immer also auf der
einen seite will man hat sich gedanken
darüber gemacht man ist da auch glaube
ich gut dabei die menschen zu schützen
auch gleichzeitig das problem das sind
wir wir werden momentan dermaßen
abgehängt von china und den usa
und die frage ist ob wir mit unseren
jetzigen gesetz zum beispiel da
mithalten können und also ich finde es
selber ganz ganz schwierig ein ganz
sensibles thema ist zum beispiel thema
daten etwas halt in europa oder in
europäischen in deutschland ganz
besonders
unfassbar schwierig ist mit diesem
großen datenmengen zu arbeiten weil das
rechtlich oftmals nicht erlaubt ist das
ist aber die basis von künstlicher
intelligenz und deswegen weiß ich nicht
ob das ob das nur gut zu betrachten so
dass man muss irgendwie abwägen müssten
ich finde ich nicht schlecht ich finde
es gut dass ich meine daten löschen kann
aber es muss halt irgendwie es ist
schwierig wenn ich als deutsches
unternehmen oder als europäisches
unternehmen viel schlechter mit daten
arbeiten kann als neuem us unternehmen
und des w
da total hinter henkel also das problem
ist ist das finde ich auch gut aber die
vielen ich sage mal hörten die du jetzt
hast bei der datenverarbeitung eher
erschweren einfach den praktischen
umgang begann also selbst als kleines
unternehmen
bist du von aufgaben gestellt die
einfach komplett würde ich jetzt mal
sagen ja das ist einfach total also dass
auch ich finde lebensfremd kein mensch
ich kann das ja also was ich viel besser
fände wenn es wenn es die möglichkeit
gebe wenn die das betriebssystem
programmierer oder jetzt darauf einen
eigenen app back end haben müsste wo du
das entscheidet und dass ich nicht bei
jeder blöden webseite jetzt immer
cookies bestätigen muss es ist so krank
warum kann das nicht zentral gesteuert
werden dass werden im klacks für die für
die hersteller der betriebssysteme das
zentral zu steuern das haben die ja auch
alles schon nur es wird halt nicht so
zentral für alle möglichen interfaces
angewendet aber das könnte ja und so
macht überhaupt keinen sinn also ich
finde
vielleicht erstmal ganz gut wenn man
immer mal wieder daran erinnert wird
dass man da gerade daten abgibt aber ich
habe das einmal die steuer ist wenn ich
einmal sage mein geburtsdatum soll immer
abgefragt werden oder mein name muss
nicht abgefragt werden oder alle dürfen
wir gerne ihre werbung zeigen oder oder
oder
das kannst du noch einmal entscheiden
aber das problem ist dass also das ja so
ein die sein ding wo ganz viele film
mitarbeiten dass also die sich fragen
dann ist ein daten verarbeiten und wir
haben das so komplex gemacht dass du da
absichtlich so ein bisschen in die
falsche richtung also gesetzlich regeln
an die macht dieses gesetz gemacht hat
der mensch ein klick mehr machen muss
man eine webseite öffnen habe ich
nochmal und ein bild klicken um die 100
sich meine daten löschen darf und dass
es nicht gut ist da habe ich schon immer
mal machen
ich finde die regelung nicht in nicht
schlecht aber zum beispiel adressdaten
adressdaten sind öffentlich die kann ich
mir das ist wie häuser unkenntlich
machen bei google maps finde ich sowas
von bescheuert weil jeder kann aussehen
je das ist öffentlich und nicht so
einfach sein
[Musik]
also was kannst du einem haus erkennen
also ich wusste nicht was brächte ein
oder nicht
also einig dann kannst du ja aber das
ist eine klassische nicht so viele
menschen entscheiden da kannst du gleich
die gegend aber das weiß jeder dass du
in köln hahnwald ganz gut beute machen
kannst und in sulz vielleicht lässt als
er ist
das cover wohnt habe jeder ein genießer
gibt nein leute gewohnt haben dann weiß
man ganz schnell das sind die dicken
will aber dabei noch gute leute
ich finde das alles hanebüchen ist
wichtige daten keine ahnung was kaufe
ich einen rat gibt es diese scheiß
payback karte und die leute wissen auch
nicht dass sie sich nackig machen aber
dafür kriegen sie geld wird ja aber so
wenig das ist so lächerlich das ist ich
mache das gerne persönlich bei keine
ahnung und im bio laden hier zum
beispiel wo ich dann weiß ich kriege
aber auch richtig rabatt wenn ich
einkaufe und nicht diese dieses diese
glas also das ist ja wie die die
westeuropäer die nach usa gekommen sind
in den indianern glasplatten geschenkt
haben also das ist einfach zu billig
abgekauft weil meine daten sind
wirklichen wert und die gebe ich auch
gerne wenn sie einen wert darstellen und
ich damit noch nutzen habe aber wenn ich
die nicht habe dann gebe ich so ungerne
und das würde ich nicht wenn ich
generell gerne entscheidender nicht auf
jeder blöden webseite zum beispiel ich
habe das gefühl ist ein bisschen vom
thema abgerückt meinst du
so wird vielleicht tatsächlich auch
einfach mal zum ende kommen 30 eine
sache zu den sieben gesetzen kann mal
dass die fragestellung war vielleicht
sogar ganz gut in die ki
diese nicht befolgen würde denn wenn man
lassen je nachdem jemand der aus malta
gesetzt sagt ja wenn die ki oder der
roboter muss die menschheit beschützen
und dürfte dafür sogar regel nummer eins
verletzen denn er darf menschen
umbringen und die menschheit zu retten
darf die also jeden suv fahrer umbringen
weil der wahrheit der co2 aus stimmt da
wird wenn wir wieder beim thema kurzer
zeit war die frage ob die gal und seine
umbringt ja dann garten vergessen das
ist ein zwischen ist und die findet die
0 3 wenn man die nötige auslässt dann
macht das von irgendwo ergibt das sinn
aber auch da wirst du definitiv felder
haben wo man es irgendwie auslegen kann
ich glaube nicht dass man das berühmte
und so reinkommen kann das immer
funktioniert
wir halten die nennt sich das despoten
mord arabischen despoten umringt darf
ich ja umbringen da wie stalin umbringen
oder darf ich das nicht als christ zum
beispiel darf ich das obwohl in den zehn
geboten besteht darf sich töten da wuchs
dann doch weil es eben in dem fall die
nolte regel gelten würde
nicht umsonst heißt sie 0 regel weil sie
so in den zehn geboten eben nicht
existiert und deswegen glaube ich halte
persönlich dass sie also es gab schon
ein zwei und drei haben irgendwie sinn
ergeben und diese 0
das war dann so was wo man irgendwie
noch mal also kann also machen wir einen
drauf setzen wollte drin ich weiß ja
nicht aber ich finde tatsächlich erstmal
es ist es machbar diese gesetze
einzubauen glaube ich wir werden nie
immer eine kontrollfunktion
wahrscheinlich haben bei der ganzen
geschichte
es ist auch realistisch dass die als war
auch gefragt ob die caritas falsch
interpretieren könnte ich glaube das
kann man zumindest relativ gut vorher
trainieren einstellen was passieren
würde wenn sie sich nicht mehr daran
hält darf daher möchte ich gar nicht
nachdenken über na ja ich habe mal
gehört dass in den mast gesagt hat die
ki wird uns alle umbringen damit der
wenn in fünf jahren einen tesla
irgendwie eine menschenmenge gerast
sagen kann ich habe es euch ja vorher
schon gesagt es ist nicht so dass ich da
hast du gesagt hätte dass meine theorie
also es ist immer dann ist es immer sehr
leicht alles vor allem zu wahren weil
irgendwann legt man dann richtig das
stimmt dass er in diesem sinne
wir haben jetzt wieder haben wir fehler
gemacht mal eine stunde 18 minuten
wahnsinn wahnsinn wahnsinn
also es ist bleibt uns alle würde ich
jetzt mal sagen ich glaube es werden
nicht mehr so viele wenn man jetzt
youtube regeln nicht mehr so viele
prangen sein und das bis zum schluss
verfolgt haben also die navi laden die
können mahnen erster schreiben die
schreiben irgendwas innen kommen den
korrekten computer vision in die
kommentare wenn ihr bisher geschaut hat
computer vision darunter vision machine
learning finde ich computer gesagt für
ihn kommt wieder wissen schreibt für
mich mit den bananen brot gott und für
mich was fragt ihr denn für mich
schreibt er bietet das schreibt keiner
opulenten von domicil mit fragiler
transparenter aus die struktur sollten
sich von der umfunktionierung von
gegenreformation resistenter materie zu
großprojekten distanzieren vielen dank
damit bleibt an was ist das
von welchem bus projektil distanzieren
wir im glas aus weil ich mit stand